I was informed by Mr Davies when I
walked into the office this morning that
the new trailer for Grand Theft Auto has
come out and when I was we lad I
remember the first time I saw Grand
Theft Auto my stepbrother showed me
Grand Theft Auto 3 I was not much of a
video game person and so he had the game
going and he said hey you got to see
this new video game and I looked and at
that moment he zoomed in with a sniper
rifle and blew some guy's head off and I
said what you know my experience at
video games had mostly been Donkey Kong
Country and Super Smash Brothers said
what an and then you know you're driving
you're speeding you're crashing cars
you're picking up hookers it was just
nuts you're dealing drugs it was the
craziest game ever and then when the
next one came out Grand Theft Auto Vice
City I got the game and I played I
actually played the game a fair bit it
was so shocking at a certain point the
the kind of craziness wears off and then
you just stop playing it but I I got a
real look maybe it's a shame to say it
is a shame to say but I did get a real
kick out of it well now there's a new
Grand Theft Auto this is Grand Theft
Auto 6 it was released 15 hours ago and
it and the trailer for
this this video game now has 70 million
views you could you could assassinate
basically any world
leader on camera post it to YouTube I'm
not sure it would get views as quickly
as this video game trailer has so I have
not seen it yet viewer discretion
advised just from what I remember about
Grand Theft Auto but I got to see it
take it
[Music]
away luia yeah do you know why you're
here bad luck I
guess put a pause Here video games have
gotten so realistic I haven't played
video games probably since Grand Theft
Auto Vice
City that's insane that looks like a
movie the mouth moves a little bit weird
but wow man that's spooky okay keep
going there was a girl
a she said she cared about
me she tried to make my
world the way she thought it should
be yeah we were desperate
then to have each other all but
[Applause]
love is a long long
[Music]
road well look who's
back the only way we're going to get
through
this is by sticking together being a
[Music]
team
trust
[Music]
[Applause]
trust it looks
amazing I I probably won't play it
because I'm a grown man with multiple
children and I don't that's not fair
that's not fair look Drew claven he's a
gamer I know there are plenty of
respectable men who are Gamers I'm not
right now go to hall.com the holidays
are rapidly approaching but we can find
peace in the craziness of the season
with hallow the number one Christian
Prayer app in the world immerse yourself
in Christmas and Advent prayers
meditations and peaceful Christmas music
hallo also offers an extensive library
of Bible reading plans accompanied by
insightful Reflections and audio guided
meditations whether you are a seasoned
Bible reader or just starting your
journey hallow provides a platform for
you to engage with scripture like never
before a great place to start is with
father Mike schmitz's Bible in the year
in which he offers brief daily readings
and Reflections available on the Hallow
app the Hallow app also helps you
connect with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with PR
meditation and Christmas music on hallow
Advent music as I prefer download the
app for free at hall.com
canw for 3 months free that is hall.com
right now go to preborn docomo finally
the perfect gift for someone who has
everything a gift that will reach
eternity pre-born gives this gift 200
times every day rescuing babies whose
lives are in Peril these babies lives
are precious and beautiful their heart
begins to form a conception and at just
3 weeks it's already beating at 5 weeks
a baby's heartbeat can be heard on
ultrasound by 6 weeks eyes are forming
by 10 weeks a baby can suck his or her
thumb pre-born needs our help to save
these precious souls for just $28 you
can sponsor an ultrasound and introduce
a mother to her baby which doubles that
baby's chance at life and right now
through a matching Grant your gift saves
twice as many babies please give the
gift of Life they fundrais separately
for their administrative cost so every
dollar you give goes right toward saving
babies this is where you've got to give
especially as the end of the year
approaches have your donation matched
today by dialing pound 250 saying the
keyword baby that is pound 250 keyword
baby or donate securely at pre-born
docomo canw that is pre-born
docomo
because it actually is all about
Vice and even looking at you know like a
woman twerking on a car or whatever I
thought is it
have the graphics gotten so good that
this could actually
be pornographic or at least titillating
and a maybe maybe they have the graphics
look insane
there and the other reason that I
probably won't play it is because when
you do things even virtually maybe
especially virtually they do sort to to
warp your
soul so it's not as much as if you
actually engage in a behavior with your
whole body that will more shape a habit
but what's spooky about the virtual
stuff is you're not conscious of it so
it's forming your desires and warping
your soul without you even being aware
of it which is why it is especially
pernicious so I probably won't do that
because what I would do if I I wouldn't
play the missions I'd probably just go
around like shooting people and stuff
and robbing people and you know just
doing all these kind of crazy things uh
so I probably won't do
that but I guess the argument to play
the game is this doesn't just seem like
pornography this doesn't just seem like
I don't know like a hedonistic do
whatever you want there there's a story
to it here clearly in the trailer
they're telling some kind of a narrative
there's obviously gameplay so you do
different missions and things it's all
pretty dark and bad but I would watch a
I would watch a dark movie I would read
a dark book if there were some redeeming
literary or
artistic um Merit to it and there
probably is if anyone is going to have
artistic Merit in an extremely dark
degenerate Narrative of of a video game
it would be Grand Theft Auto these guys
are whatever you want to say about it
these guys are clearly excellent artists
o I'm really I am actually tempted to
play the game I probably won't also
because I'm too cheap and I won't buy a
new video game system
but that's impressive come a long way
since Donkey
Kong which remains my favorite video
game perhaps until now boy what a great
clip that was now hey hey hey ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time